John Bernthal stole the show as Shane
Walsh on The Walking Dead even though
his time on the series was limited it
had serious ramifications for the rest
of his life and career Rick and Shane
were the first roles to be cast for The
Walking Dead and when John Bernthal went
into his audition he initially read for
Rick's part Bernthal said that despite
reading for Rick from very early in the
casting process he wanted the role of
Shane showrunner Frank darbun warned
Bernthal that The Walking Dead comics
killed Shane off early in their run that
wasn't a big concern for Bernthal who
told Entertainment Weekly
I know it sounds cheesy but I want to
serve the story and I always said
Shane's got to go and if that really
Services the story then by all means I'm
down for that he was excited when Andrew
Lincoln was cast as Rick the two became
best friends and they still have a close
relationship to this day when it was
time for Bernthal to leave the show he
said it's been the honor of my acting
career to act alongside Andrew Lincoln
luckily it wasn't the last time the two
got to be on screen with each other in
the early days of The Walking Dead few
people thought the show would become a
record-breaking success AMC picked up
the first season for only six episodes a
sure sign that the network didn't have
full confidence in the series the
ratings in 2010 proved that the zombie
apocalypse was a hit with viewers but
the show didn't become the phenomenon it
is today until season 3 when its ratings
doubled when John Bernthal worked on The
Walking Dead the series functioned much
more like a lowbudget passion project
speaking about his time on the show with
comic book.com Bernthal said when we did
Walking Dead there were no trailers
there were no craft Services we would
just hike out into the woods it was very
humble helping to create The Walking
Dead taught Bernthal that with enough
hard work and dedication a creative team
really can take a far-fetched idea and
turn it into an unprecedented hit
Bernthal said he went a little method
when it came to playing Shane Walsh
Bernthal did his best to really get
himself into Shane's mindset while
portraying the character the focus comes
through in Shane's unique gate and
tendency to scratch at his head
according to Bernthal the uneasiness of
Shane's physicality shows how he is at
constant odds with himself and his
actions the dedic ation to his character
bled into bernthal's everyday life he
said that fighting zombies day in and
day out while filming truly made him
hate the creatures while working on the
show he'd frequently have dreams about
fighting zombies in character when he
saw fans of the show dressed as zombies
at conventions he joked that he wanted
to attack bernthal's method acting on
The Walking Dead carried over to the
rest of his career in 2016 he told Jimmy
Kimmel that he stayed in character
between takes on the sets of Daredevil
and The Punisher yeah a little bit
really yeah I know it sounds so
pretentious so do you punish people uh
you around punishing some might credit
Shane as being the first villain in The
Walking Dead But the character really is
more of a hero than a villain in the
beginning of the show he saves Lori and
garl and he helps lead a whole group of
survivors to safety while tensions rise
between Rick and Shane's leadership
styles throughout season 2 Shane is
still fully committed to doing what he
thinks is best for the survival of the
group Bernthal believes that even in
Shane's final moments he's acting in the
interest of the group he thinks there's
a part of Shane that believes he can no
longer be around the others by
threatening Rick in the episode better
Angels he's really forcing his friend to
be the kind of man who can make
difficult decisions on behalf of
everyone else Bernthal thinks Shane is
almost sacrificing himself for the
betterment of the group of course the
Punisher is Marvel's most famous
anti-hero and his pursuit of justice and
Daredevil certainly has that sort of
attitude the work Bernthal put into
crafting Shane as a sympathetic
anti-hero arguably helped prepare him
for his next major role the early days
of The Walking Dead were like a pressure
cooker for the team involved in creating
AMC's zombie apocalypse the project
brought everyone close together and
Bernthal found a family among his
co-workers on the show he grew very
close to Frank darbun the show's Creator
and first showrunner and Andrew Lincoln
who auditioned for the show alongside
Bernthal speaking to comicbook.com
Bernthal said those folks are still some
of my best friends in the world and the
bonds that were formed in the beginning
of that show a family was formed he says
that Lincoln has become like a brother
to him in bernthal's opinion those close
bonds helped to make the show as special
as it is he learned that genuine
connections on set spill onto the screen
they not only make filming a show more
enjoyable but they also make the series
better for its viewers anyone is bound
to pick up a few survival tips and
tricks while spending years working on a
show about living in a post-apocalyptic
world that's especially true for
Bernthal since his character has a
heightened survival Instinct even when
compared to the other characters on The
Walking Dead there's nothing that Shane
won't do to keep himself and the people
he cares about alive even if that means
abandoning some pre-apocalypse morality
when asked if starring on the show
improved his odds of survival in a real
zombie apocalypse Bernthal said it had
because he learned a few new tricks
however that doesn't mean he thinks that
he'd make it in the long run according
to Bernthal when the going gets tough no
one will make it out alive that's a
disappointing prognosis for the state of
humanity but it comes straight from the
horse's mouth I sat there and I weeped
and you know I felt sorry for myself and
I knew it was over Shane's death on The
Walking Dead was one of the show's most
dramatic moments early in its run
despite Bernthal saying he is happy for
being a part of it and getting out when
he did his exit was more emotional off
screen than in the series itself Shane
died in better Angels the second to last
episode of season 2 Burnal shot his
final scene with Andrew Lincoln and they
were joined by the rest of the show's
cast the group spent the entire night in
a field by Hershel's Farmhouse making
sure that they got the scene just right
even Jeff deun whose character Dale had
died an episode previously made sure he
was on set for bernthal's last scene he
flew out to the set in Georgia from his
farm in Upstate New York to be there for
the sendoff rendal described shooting
his final scene in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly he said and to go
out the way I did and go out with who I
did it was and still is very emotional
the scene finished shooting at 6:00 a.m.
after which the cast quietly walked back
to the farm where Bernthal gave a Tey
speech to close things out bernthal's
last shoot wasn't supposed to be his
last day on set The Walking Dead still
needed to film the season 2 finale and
Bernthal was invited out to the set to
join the cast for filming he hiked out
to Hershel's farm with Saro Callie
intending to spend the day with his
co-stars but he couldn't bring himself
to do it bernola said he saw everyone
out on the farm gearing up to film The
chaotic conclusion to season 2 and he
had a sense that the show was theirs now
and that it was time to move on instead
of joining everyone on set Bernthal
found a place in the woods to sit back
and watch the filming by himself he
later laughed about what happened on his
actual last day telling Entertainment
Weekly I sound like the biggest weirdo
in the world but I didn't say goodbye I
couldn't do not mess this up before
joining The Walking Dead Bernthal split
his time between acting for the camera
and acting on the stage talking about
his starting acting Bernthal said he was
first exposed to the craft when a class
in college he credits his Professor with
truly making him fall in love with
acting she encouraged him to study in
Moscow and after that Bernthal attended
the artt at Harvard where he earned his
MFA early on he had no interest in
becoming a TV or film star and preferred
being a theater actor he spent years
acting on the stage and slowly started
taking Parts in films and television
Pilots when he first read the pilot
script for The Walking Dead he told his
agent he would even be an extra on the
show Bernthal actually turned down work
offers on the off chance that he got a
part in The Walking Dead when he was C
in the show Bernthal completely
dedicated himself to making it a success
The Walking Dead outperformed everyone's
expectations and Bernthal himself was a
major part of that the role became his
breakthrough and he's been steadily
starring in shows and films ever since
there always comes a time when an actor
stops keeping up with the show after
they've left it Bernthal revealed that
he stopped watching The Walking Dead for
Fairly mundane reasons after playing
Shane his career skyrocketed and his
schedule became much busier on top of
that Bernthal has a family of his own
including three children and a handful
of pitbulls while Bernthal said he
stopped watching the series he told
Jake's takes um I'm I'm enormously
grateful for that show and I'm
enormously grateful of the people I got
to make it with despite his busy
schedule Bernthal has found the time to
make two guest appearances on The
Walking Dead after his departure the
first was in season 3 episode 8 and the
second was in season 9 episode 5 he also
still stays in touch with the crew
behind the series saying they will
always be like family to
[Music]
him